Tom Brady by all accounts by all reports
and the first guy to reported and this
is the kind of thing that drives the
five-minute heads-up NFL insiders crazy
Colin coward had it yesterday Tampa Bay
Buccaneers the next destination for Tom
Brady it was down to the Buccaneers and
the Chargers Chris and ultimately for a
lot of the reasons I believe that you
articulated yesterday Tom Brady decides
to stay east coast to stay in reasonable
proximity in New York City and also
reasonable proximity of Costa Rica and
Brazil not go back to California go to
Florida play for the Buccaneers play for
Bruce Arians the exact opposite of Bill
Belichick how do you think this came to
be and how do you think it's gonna work
well you know this is this is the reason
when I had first heard that the 49ers
were out of the conversation with Brady
I had been led to believe all along that
like I had told you with people in the
know about this situation that really
the 49ers were the only team on the west
coast that I think Brady was willing to
go and make that move and be that far
from the family and have that stress on
the family so you know I had heard the
rumors about the Chargers but that's why
I ultimately said I think it's gonna be
Patriots or Bucs because I just didn't
think there was a real chance one of the
people in the know that I know about one
of the last things he told me was you
know that little tidbit I said about the
49ers so how did it come to be you know
first off we know that New England
played hardball and and really didn't
you know want to offer him a respectable
deal or make him feel warm comfortable
respect them whatever it may be
the Chargers I do I think it's just too
much stress on his family as we know
he's got family up here in the New York
area he wants to see them it's easy to
get flights from Tampa back to here any
one of the three airports you can go and
do a LaGuardia JFK Newark you know even
up here in Greenwich you know where he's
supposedly gonna move to there's a White
Plains Airport that's very close to his
new house if that's supposedly it or
comes to be true and then Mike you said
it I mean the Bucs are just like they're
starving for this kind of guy and
they're the opposite of New England he's
gonna have a head coach now that's
instead of being in the general or
dictator is like his buddy and he's
gonna be like what we're having a
conversation about the
I like and we're talking about things we
did after work yesterday this is crazy
and I think that probably appealed to
Tom Brady let alone he knows there's
some potential with that team and the
weapons they got around him now and my
understanding is that Brady and his camp
presented to the Buccaneers and the
Chargers what he wants financially that
wasn't a subject of negotiation there
were other terms he wanted not the kind
of crazy stuff that some people are
suggesting like control over the roster
and control over the offense I don't
think he wants to be Peyton Manning
because he's never been Peyton whitey
when Peyton Manning went to Denver he
just continued what he'd always been Tom
Brady is that student of do your job
very linear he will bust his ass yeah to
master the offense he doesn't want to
design the offense right so look he made
it clear what he wanted the Buccaneers
and the Chargers were the two that bit
and ultimately Tampa Bay for the reasons
you identified not and also no state
income taxes and if you're a
gazillionaire that's a factor because
it's more money in your pocket at the
end of the day proximity to New York
where his son with Bridget Moynahan
lives proximity to as I said South
America Brazil Gisele Bundchen's home
country Costa Rica where they have a
place I'd like to go to Miami that's why
the Dolphins were considered a
possibility at all this chair so Tampa
and also look strategically you don't
have to screw around with Patrick
mahomes twice a year you got a chance to
win the division you got a chance to
maybe host a playoff game and if you
make it to the Super Bowl you're playing
it in your own stadium no no doubt about
it I mean I think those are all
positives and you know hey Tom Brady or
not you know the Buccaneers are one of
those teams that you know I think we
both would agree you we'd circle right
now as long as they got a quarterback
that we felt was comfortable we'd go
watch out for the Bucks
they have potential to be dangerous now
of course with Tom Brady that raises
that level up to you know another tier
by being like oh they're dangerous now
for sure I mean yeah you said it Mike
he's not the kind of guy that wants to
instill his office he'll give some ideas
and some thoughts and all that but
you're right that's what's awesome about
Brady he's the ultimate soldier just
tell him what you want him to do he's in
a busted
but at it he knows how to play he's
gifted he still got a great arm to throw
the ball down the field in the Bruce
Arians Byron Leftwich type offense man a
guy like Mike Evans and Chris Godwin and
he's a type of quarterback that really
knows how to use a tight end man I bet
he'll help out Oh J Howard a lot so
there's so many positives there let
alone Mike I mean their front seven and
then their front seven scary jpp
Shaquille Barrett Vito they are vitae
via whatever the hell his name is the
two linebackers they got at the second
level I mean they have a real chance
here to be special and be a pain in the
butt not only in the NFC South but in
the NFC in general I agree with you
completely seven and nine last year with
Jameis Winston throwing 30 interceptions
and it really was his performance down
the stretch that caused Bruce Arians to
genuinely sour on Jameis Winston Ira
Kaufman of Joe Buck's fan calm who's
covered the Buccaneers forever right
covered the Buccaneers win you oh my god
he said those last two games are what
did it and he said to me Chris that if
Jameis Winston he'll ask him this
question if Jameis Winston in overtime
of the week 17 loss to the Falcons
instead takes the Buccaneers down the
field and wins the game instead of
throwing a pick six that ended the
season Tom Brady wouldn't be poised to
join the Buccaneers that would have been
enough to keep Jameis Winston in Tampa
it was the way the season ended the way
that last game ended the way that he got
230 interceptions that made Bruce Arians
say I just can't do it and that's when
they started looking and they quickly
landed on Tom Brady yeah that's right I
mean the last game of course concerning
and am I am I right was the second to
last game that Saturday afternoon game
against the Houston Texans where the
Texas gave him every chance to win right
and he spotted them what'd I get
21-point lead basically early on cuz he
was you know Johnny interception bills
so I get it when you do those type of
things at the end of the year it's gonna
leave a bad taste in the organization's
mouth the head coach's mouth as they go
into the offseason and I'm sure that was
a little bit of a tipping point yeah I'm
not shocked to hear that you know I just
I've been around football a long time
you know you can you can fool the whole
organization by having a positive last
two or three weeks to where they go see
this is what we like about this guy's
got potential he's going in the right
direction the next year
well it can very easily go the other way
as we're seeing here and this is awesome
I mean I'm really excited for the
Buccaneers the Glazer family the Tampa
Bay Buccaneer fans there are awesome fan
bases I told you and they are gonna
treat him like the king of Tampa I mean
he's gonna go down there and just he's
gonna be shocked about how much they
love football and the atmosphere around
that organization IRA Kauffman told me
that the lead item on the NBC local
affiliate news last night wasn't kovat
19 wasn't the Florida primary it was Tom
Brady is coming to Tampa they're
flooding the phone lines to ultimately
get season tickets and that Jersey that
Jersey is gonna sell would know Jersey
has ever sold before and Chris I looked
at the schedule today they've got at
home Oh Aaron Rodgers and the Green Bay
Packers
Patrick mahomes your homey and my homey
homina Tampa Jared Goff and the Rams go
to Tampa the Vikings and Kirk Cousins
the Chargers who were spurned by Tom
Brady oh by the way he plays Drew Brees
twice combined quarterback age of 84
road games at Detroit against Matt
Patricia and the Lions and Matthew
Stafford they go to face the Giants a
team that's 2a no against Brady in the
Super Bowl they go to Las Vegas to play
the Raiders they go to Denver where
Brady has always struggled this is one
hell of a schedule Chris I was excited
about the 49ers schedule with Brady
because they go to New England this is
the best schedule you could get without
Brady playing the Patriots and who knows
maybe come early February maybe if the
world gets back on its axis it'll be the
Patriots and the Buccaneers in Super
Bowl 55 in Tampa well yeah I'm not ready
to quite to go there you know I need to
go figure out who's the quarterback of
the Patriots but we know they're not a
fairly important Indian but we know the
Patriots I'm not counting them out I'm
not counting them you know four dead
here just because Tom Brady's not there
no I'm not I mean it's just there's too
many special people still up there and
that organization but man you're right
it's it's like a world tour I mean it's
really who's who of who's playing Tampa
where are they going I mean it's gonna
be really cool and Mike I think you know
you hit on it the other element to this
that I'm really excited about right is
Brady versus Brees I mean
first off these two are psychos they're
psycho competitors do I think there's a
little bit of a competition right now
for the touchdown pass mark and things
like that you know you know we talked
about all the reasons we think Brady
might go to Tampa we hit on all those do
I also think that he knows he can go
there and put up big numbers and put a
little pressure on Drew Brees as we go
here to cuz I think Brady wants to have
every record known to mankind and the
quarterback and I'm all for it go for it
Tommy
but I think that's a cool aspect of this
as well drew Brees currently has 547
career touchdown passes Tom Brady has
541 and the thinking is Brady is going
to play it longer than Brees IRA Kaufman
agrees with my assessment two years for
Brady in Tampa two years for Bruce
Arians and then they ride off into the
sunset together with or without a Super
Bowl championship and see here's the
thing
yes Tom Brady would love to get number
seven and who knows maybe he will with
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers but when a team
that clearly and obviously is in the mix
to compete for a Super Bowl isn't saying
we want Tom Brady he's got to move on to
the next plan and when the 49ers say no
thanks and when he's getting the vibe
the Patriots don't want him then you
roll your dice with the Buccaneers and I
think he's got a better chance with the
Buccaneers than he had or would have had
with the LA Chargers whether or not that
manifests itself in a postseason
appearance a Super Bowl appearance we'll
see but it's gonna be a fun ride and I
you know I I hope that we get a full
football season with all the stuff
that's going on in the world I hope that
it calms down enough I hope the NFL is
making the right plans
I hope the testing will get to the point
where maybe they can just test every
player before every game and if
everyone's clean go out and play and if
somebody's not there out that week until
they're clear of the virus but whatever
the case may be I hope we get 16 games
because it's gonna be great 16 games
involving the Tampa Bay Buccaneer
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports